les pires raison de ruptures puisse
cuves dans la pièce la perruche charrier
et barbara jouent un couple au bord de
la rupture et du qu'on va jouer et que
vous les chroniqueurs et vos rupture
alors il ya des ruptures qui vont
apparaître
à votre avis quelles ruptures correspond
à quelques chroniqueurs à ce qu'on peut
faire apparaître au niveau des gels à
guînes personnes par courrier mail ne
l'a jamais reçu alors par courrier ça a
moins vite que ça devait être un
télégramme ça doit être isabelle
morini-bosc non à la larguer personnes
isabelle ou bien alors pu être j'ai
largué une personne par pigeon voyageur
mènera le reçu je me suis fait larguer
qu'à mon conjoint avait envie de me
claquer quand je parle et ça c'est à mon
avis c'est maxime kenny lala pense tout
de suite
non j'ai largué quelqu'un car il était
toujours d'accord avec moi à la sas et
vous non ouais et la grille quelqu'un
par contre je vais virer quelqu'un passe
à me faire chier je me suis fait larguer
par texto en pleine nuit j'ai largué
quelqu'un à cause de l'odeur de ses
pieds ça c'est assez sympa j'ai largué
la personne qui a piraté ma messagerie
je me suis fait larguer à cause du
monstre du loch ness ça c'est isabelle
morini-bosc je suis annoncé gilles icher
gilles tessier je me suis fait larguer
parce que je n'avais pas si pas pris
assez poitrine isabelle c'est bon quoi
donc elle avait envie de vous claquez
ques assad est diakhaté enchanté avec
une charmante rouquine très propre
service où elle d'état
non mais les coûts et tu crains qu'on
ait du service d'hygiène monde arabe en
avait plein de points en commun surtout
la bonne bouffe et elle avait une petite
particularité ce qu'elle me voulait
m'embrasser que sur la lèvre du bas elle
me replacer à chaque fois donc je
l'embrassé que le haut donc c'était un
petit détail en tout cas on s'entendait
bien beau de walthéry conserve one hand
et d'écrevisses et là tu dis tu vois de
demain n'en veut pas après demain je
peux pas après après demain je peux pas
et au final elle m'a envoyé un sms en
disant j'ai envie de te claquer quand tu
me parles je ne supporte pas ta voix
j'ai l'impression d'avoir à faire un
présentateur à longueur de journée ah
ouais bah je la comprends voilà c'est ça
et depuis on ne s'est jamais vu il est
reparti avec son ex non j'y suis allé
j'ai fait un effort j'étais que voir la
personne est installé tout il enlève ses
chaussures
et là je me dis mais c'est pas possible
mais ça sent les poubelles ça sent le
fromage les poubelles non c'est pas
possible
donc je regarde quand même le match je
prends sur moi et le lendemain je
retourne le voir et appareils la même
chose ils enlèvent si je suis moi le mec
en fait il voulait absolument le même si
je suis le kabyle plus des pieds c'est
pas une mais des bottes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu le sais tu fais un beau tennis tu
mets des après-ski annonce tubes à mêler
car il va absolument qu'ils disent c'est
comme les gars qui pue de la gueule ils
valent absolument vous dire des secrets
nous sommes en 1993
nous sommes quoi alors fois nous sommes
nous sommes en 1993 en écosse sur les
bords du loch ness
je vis une amourette naissante avec
catherine que je viens de rencontrer et
catherine me dit nous sommes au début de
la relation j'aime l'histoire
j'ai dit mais c'est génial je vais
t'emmener chercher le monstre du loch
ness
ça c'est de l'histoire donc nous partons
j'organise cinq jours près d'inverness
en écosse pour aller chercher le monstre
du loch ness
vous savez qu'il existe et personne n'a
encore trouvé fait ouais c'est pas beau
pour un peu comme dans tous les deux et
il pleut pendant trois jours le déluge
vous avez toujours beaucoup de chance et
moi je réponds que le lac avec catherine
comme ça auto pour trouver le monde
nomade ou rage en allemagne et kusile
c'est plus possible moi je partais pour
un petit séjour romantique ne se voit
jamais on poursuit ce [ __ ] de monde
j'en ai rien à faire n'était pas dans
ton d une super idée pourtant de ses
vitraux de conques et dépendances
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon je sois rocher je me suis fait
larguer parce que je n'avais pas à ce
prix assez poitrine isabelle alias et
moi c'est moi
alors oui et non on vous sait madonna je
suis en alsace en moi et ça peut pas
être vrai tu en as plus que moi mais
vous alors vous la poitrine oui ah oui
mais ça ne nous était plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
j'avais 11 ans et j'avais un garçon qui
était qui m'aimait vraiment beaucoup
aimé visiter pas joli pour l'instant de
tout frisé tout noir au 2010 était tout
ce joli petit pavé jolie pour l'instant
mais dans quatre cinq ans que tu sera
parfaite
t'auras prix de la poitrine tôt rapide
et fort visionnaire à 4,510 donc à 11
mars
non mais il avait une très belle vue
c'est barras et moi s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
j'avais un copain l'époque s'appelait
alexis est maintenant à quoi tu remets
pas en quoi faire mais ce n'est pas le
taux de dossiers d'accord mais pas cet
ex mari maintenant oui mais en fait
c'est lui c'est avec ces il avait une
petite chienne un cocker ou qui
s'appelait madonna alsacienne à chaque
fois qu'on était ensemble
madonna était père agressive avec moi
ouais un jour où on fait des choses à
mal et akpala que virgin dirais à jour
on fait les choses un peu plus coquine
sur le canapé ah oui madonna moment le
mollet
[Rires]
alors moi je m'énerve juni alexis
maintenant c'est madonna ou moi et m'a
dit si tu m'aimes
c'est un que c'est un lot c'est madonna
et moi il m'a dit faut choisir c'est
dumas écoute moi je ne choisis pas les 2
est donc finalement il m'a dit moi je
garde madonna il m'a largué non mais il
a préféré même il a préféré une chaîne à
vous il est préféré madonna a à moi de
le dire je veux dire le cheikh brahim et
de quoi le charme et mieux la cus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]